because what we see and this was a good
example the other day of the Department
of Justice not going after officer
Pantaleo that you know officer Pantaleo
used a chokehold that was prohibited by
NYPD he did that for seven seconds
eleven different times Eric garner said
that he couldn't breathe he knew what he
was doing that he was killing Eric
garner and yet he has not been brought
to justice that police officer should be
off the street why is that police
officer still on the force the one who
killed Eric Gardner please respond let
me tell you I know the garner family
they've gone through extraordinary pain
they're waiting for justice and are
going to get justice there's finally
going to be justice I accomplished in
that in the next thirty days in New York
you know why because for the first time
we are not waiting on the federal
Justice Department which told the city
of New York that we could not proceed
because the Justice Department was
pursuing their prosecution and years
went by and a lot of pain accrued and
the meantime what I'm working on is
making sure and I have for five years
there will never be another tragedy
they'll never beat another Eric garner
because we're changing fundamentally how
we police think you know there's one
last point out this